I'm Jam supernova and I'm a DJ and
broadcaster and I'm going to be speaking
to you about the DIY generation my
generation and generation after the ones
that doing it for ourselves we're taking
control of our own careers and futures
so the financial crash happened ten
years ago when I was actually in college
and I remember there was such a
uncertainty in the air and even the
teachers they were scared for our
futures a few years after that
university tuition freeze went up and
more recently zero-hour contracts have
been introduced and for some people
living on a zero hours contract just
isn't good enough for them to survive so
I felt that our generation have had to
be the hustla generation we've had to
make things our own and build their own
careers and decide how much money we
want to earn and I think that's where
that kind of hustler mentality comes and
I think we're definitely the hustler
generation social medias also played a
massive part in the DIY generation
literally if you have a phone anyone can
have a business if they have a social
media account you could do it from your
bedroom it's given anyone a voice now
it's cut out the middleman or woman and
it's changed a job market I really feel
like the Internet has driven a massive
change so I've definitely benefited from
the internet I started my journey on
Soundcloud and I would upload radio
shows every single week to my SoundCloud
account and SoundCloud for those that
don't know it's a music platform which
lets you upload content so music content
Rivage productions remixes or mixes in
itself you can make money from streaming
by putting your music or distribute your
music onto Spotify or Apple music or
Beatport so Isis are doing that now
they're also making money from live
shows and by building their following on
SoundCloud they were able to get live
shows and bookings the whole game has
changed
I feel like now the artist is in control
and they're the ones that have got the
power and they can say no I don't think
I want a contract like that or actually
you might have to give me that you know
I'm independent there's been an
incredible rise of young people running
businesses just using their social media
accounts or using it the social media
accounts to propel their businesses for
example you have someone like Vikki
grout so she's a photographer and she
came up shooting up-and-coming Brian axe
and her portfolio was her Instagram and
that's what was used to build a
following but then also to get
overworked so she now she does
incredible campaigns people like Mike or
front cover shoots Elias it's amazing to
see how she's grown and then you've also
got people like poets and Charlie cooks
she decided to write a poem a day for a
month I'm showcasing on Instagram and by
the end of the month she had an agent
and a book deal so this kind of online
culture is really challenging nepotism
you can get headhunted just from your
online portfolio alone whether it's an
Instagram whether it's Twitter whether
it's YouTube and I think it's definitely
challenging some of the old ways in
which we thought we had to get jobs and
this kind of change is making us more
creative take for example golden slay
run an online magazine for women of
color by women of color and they'd
created it because they weren't seeing
themselves reflected in mainstream media
there's also the noticeable generation
gap so the things that my generation and
the younger generation place value on is
very different to what our old
generation did or does and they place
value on 9:00 to 5:00 getting secure job
getting a pension I definitely think
that we are definitely more risk takers
and we go against the status quo and I
think the things that we place value on
comes down to happiness
a creative outlet and expression so we
spoke a lot about the great things about
DIY generation but of course if
everything they're going to be downsides
as well not everyone has the financial
backing to get them through dry spells
everyone has the luxury to be able to
focus on their dreams full time I think
they're the sort of downsides that we
don't often talk about and there are
lonely times as well imagine you miss
birthdays christenings and like a
samurai's result in the breakdown of
relationships because you are so
one-shot minded on your dreams and your
goals and what you need to do but that's
also positive and I think it's a common
trait we're persistent as well so I was
told for five years now you're not good
enough for a radio show not yet not yet
not yet and I just carried on knocking
and eventually got my own radio show
the DIY generation fever is spreading
even the older generation are starting
to think more like us to people working
multiple jobs having side hustles
creating their own businesses as well
and I think it's going to be really
exciting to see what happens with the
younger generation the faster internet
with the bare apps the better phones to
see what they can create and what they
can do I think that the world will
definitely be there Easter
you